magnus shaking his head he knows this
one has gone all winning chances have
disappeared he gives another check he's
setting a trap if black takes this pawn
with his king then the white queen would
have given a check and actually picked
off black's rook in the left corner
there but no rajabov keeps his kings
safe and reduces the amount of available
checks that white can give and magnus
he's about to agree to the draw here he
repeats the position leans back in his
chair and
if he if the black king goes back where
it came from that will be the third time
we've seen this position magnus missing
some serious winning chances in this
game
yeah it's going to be a draw the first
game
and there we go there we go raj above is
he celebrating is he relieved
either way a miraculous defense from the
azerbaijani player definitely magnus
carlsen with the white pieces the first
game is a draw timor ajaba will have the
white pieces in the next game that will
start in 10 minutes from now magnus
crossing well he doesn't look too
either happy or